Und das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Hab doch gestern gesehen wie kaputt das ist.
Ist dreimal abgekackt beim Upload...
weil ich den falschen Button geklickt habe
ich höre mich schon müde an
ich bin schon eine halbe Stunde oft
aber außer dass ich der Katz was zu futtern gegeben habe und ein bisschen mit der Katz
Action gemacht habe, das habe ich unterwegs gemacht
in null
aber insofern ist es ja auch
das hat es mir angetan irgendwie
7 Monate, auch huge
ein richtig echter Sub, kein Prime Sub
aus Ägypten
aber ab hier
das lasse ich mal hier irgendwie auf, dass wir wieder sehen, falls Vodafone rumspacken
sollte
Reshade GFX Guide, Press of the World
man muss ja sagen
Nintendo Spiele auf dem Emulator
das klingt ein bisschen laut, ne?
da man eigentlich unten eingestellt, ne passt
man muss sagen, Nintendo Spiele sehen auf dem Emulator echt gut aus, das heißt
Nintendo
hat wohl
wenn man sich das so anschaut irgendwie mehr Qualität als man so auf der
ehemaligen Konsole sieht
wo sechs Monate der Stelle so am Start
Which Prime
Prime
Sub
Huge Sub
So was gibt es denn heute zu gucken? Ich würde sagen, wisst ihr was, was wir machen zum
Anfang mal wieder
wir gucken uns ein Battlefield Top Plays Video an, das finde ich
immer super zum einsteigen, weil
da muss ich nichts großartiges erzählen und kann mich einfach drüber lustig machen, wie schlecht die Gegner sind
und dann kommt mir irgendwas anderes
ich mein, okay, wir müssen jetzt ja erzählen im Prinzip eh wieder genau das gleiche, weil das
immer immer das gleiche erzählt
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield Top Plays, in todays Episode we're going to be taking a look at Battlefield 3
Battlefield 4, Battlefield Hardline
Battlefield 1 and Battlefield 5 in a special edition Episode
essentially what I'm trying to do is prove which Battlefield Game
has the most engaging and interesting Infantry Experience
da muss ich nicht lange überlegen
welches Battlefield die most engaging, was hat er erzählt, die most engaging and
Infantry Experience
engaging
Battlefield Game
has the most engaging
and interesting, engaging and interesting Battlefield Infantry Experience
ist das irgendein Marketing Mensch oder so?
der sagt schon wieder
da muss ich nicht lange überlegen
das ist für mich Bad Company 2
gleich auf mit Battlefield 3 gefolgt von Battlefield 4
Infantry Experience of course
starting out with Battlefield 3
now I have left a little voting system down below, you can click on the link
man kann voten da, wir voten mal kurz, wo kann man voten?
vote below
ah nee das ist ein komischer YouTube vote
sieht man auch irgendwie die Ergebnisse?
ah da muss man
ah ich bin mit meinem Google Fake Account hier noch angemeldet, das ist gut
ah fuck
weiß schon mein Passwort nicht mehr
dann vote ich mal kurz auf dem anderen Bildschirm dafür
Battlefield 3
ich kann am anderen Bildschirm auch nicht voten, das ist rigged
geht nicht
I did ask you guys on YouTube what you thought
about this question and the results
I look forward to seeing what you have to say
also es ist eindeutig Battlefield 3, Battlefield 3 in Bad Company 2 und danach Battlefield 4
Battlefield 1 und 5 ist das Sack dagegen was Infantry Combat angeht
starting out a couple of clips from Scream, he's playing on Battlefield 3
Max ist da ja
der Knäherbär ist auch da
heute in Person und nicht als Knäherbär gifted subs oder sowas
nee wie war das Knäherbär
gifted sub
an Knäher, irgendwie sowas
kann ihr euch noch dran erinnern wo sich alle drüber lustig gemacht haben als Battlefield 3 angesagt war
dass der Plau, also erstmal hat den Plaufilter gar keiner gemerkt am Anfang
da haben alle nur gedacht ah das Game sieht halt aus, Battlefield 3 sieht halt aus wie Battlefield 3 aussieht
und irgendwann sind die Leute drauf gekommen ah da ist ein Plaufilter drüber und haben gesagt
oh nee warum ist dieser blöde Plaufilter drüber das ist ja das Sack Kacke das will ich nicht haben
und jetzt bei den anderen Battlefield Games ist es schon wieder so mein
dass die Leute sagen
Battlefield 3 Plaufilter das hat dem Game irgendwie Charakter in Chem, ich will den Plaufilter wieder
also man kann sich nie drauf verlassen was die Spieler letztendlich sagen
liegt aber auch einfach daran wie viel Zeit dazwischen ist
ich bin immer noch den Plaufilter
ich gebraucht hätt ich nicht
es gibt ja sogar Patches die den Plaufilter removeen
das hätte ich mit 16 Euren gekriegt
16 beste
es ist lustig wie sie alle Farben-Blinden-Modus spielen in Battlefield 3
das für ne Wolke
das war schon nice
vor allem das war halt auch in Battlefield 3 richtig cool
dass du quasi flenken konntest so am Arsch der Welt rum
du konntest ja quasi Metro theoretisch hier durchschwimmen oder hinten lang flenken
keiner gemacht, aber konntest du
und du konntest halt auch in Battlefield 3 wenn du einmal hinter den Gegnern warst
du konntest dich so krass bashen
Farben-Blinden-Modus war besser in Sachen, ja war es auch deswegen spielen sie auch alle
vor allem wie es die Gegner wieder nicht checken, dass da einer bei ihnen in der Base steht
das Spotting durch den Smoke, ich hab's ja schon wieder ganz vergessen, beste
also wer in Smoke gerannt ist war in Battlefield 3 vollgefickt
wenn du gespottet warst, du hast selbst nichts gesehen, aber alle anderen haben dich im Smoke gesehen
ja Blackfly
das war echt cool
ja Blackfly, Blackfire
das liegt mit daran
weil das für viele Leute erstens mal, also er sagt hier warum
warum gab es nach Battlefield 3 kein Shooter mehr der Ansatz weil so geil war
oder bin ich voreingenommen
also ich denke mal das liegt zum ersten da dran, weil es für viele Leute so das
neben Call of Duty so das erste richtig große Battlefield war was sie gespielt haben
es kommt natürlich dabei und weil das Game auch
obwohl es erstmal nicht so aussieht
sehr viele Möglichkeiten hatte zu spielen
sei es jetzt von Infanterie bis Panzer bis Heli bis
danach haben sie mit Battlefield 4 total übertrieben
und auch obwohl es im Prinzip
selbst wenn man immer die gleiche Klasse, immer die gleiche Map
und immer die gleiche Waffen gespielt hat
du konntest trotzdem der Sache was Neues abgewinnen
außerdem war halt das Gameplay an sich gut
was das Spiel getragen hat, man musste keine
es hat auch ewig gedauert bis man Rank 100 war
allerdings nicht so lange wie in Bad Company 2
das Motivierende war halt das Gameplay an sich
und das haben sie danach nie wieder so gut hingekriegt
vielleicht noch in Battlefield 4 aber
ruckelt nichts
aber nicht mehr in der Art und Weise
es war auch nicht perfekt Battlefield 3, es hat auch viele Sachen hier abgefuckt
oh ist das Konsole?
nee
dafür ist die Auflösung so hoch
die Waffen waren auch cool
die Waffen in Battlefield 3 waren auch ziemlich cool
es gab natürlich wie immer klare OP Waffen
zum Beispiel m16 war die beste
aber wenn nicht
wenn ehrlich gesagt mit Abstand die beste Waffe im Spiel
trotzdem, du bist mit den anderen Waffen nicht automatisch
total untergegangen und die hatten halt eine gewisse
eine gewisse Eigenheit, alle Waffen in Battlefield 3
es gab zwar auch ein paar, ob du jetzt eine m16 gespielt hast
oder eine m416 oder so, das war jetzt nicht der Wahnsinnsunterschied
aber so eine Aikane, eine AM, was?
an 94, 91, wie hieß das Ding nochmal genau
und sagen wir eine Aikane an 94
und eine
m416, die haben sich alle schon ein bisschen unterschieden
und das fand ich halt das coole daran
eigentlich haben sie fast alles in Battlefield 4
noch einen Ticken besser ausgebaut
als in Battlefield 3
mehr Zeug von allem
aber irgendwie hat sie mir Battlefield 4 bei mir nicht mehr ganz so gebracht
wie Battlefield 3
und das lag bei mir persönlich zum größten Teil daran
dass die Rushmaps in Battlefield 3 einfach um Längen besser waren
als in Battlefield 4
und Rush ist nunmal mein Battlefield Lieblingsmodus
und wenn die Rushmaps nicht so gut sind, dann macht mir das ganze Spiel
nicht so viel Spaß, auch wenn es viel mehr Sachen drinne hat
ich mein die Rushmaps in Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2
und wir sagen mal Bad Company 1, 2, ist ja eh, da wurde ja Rush quasi erfunden
aber die Rushmaps
in Battlefield 3
waren einfach auch noch mal mit die besten, die sie gemacht haben
ich mein, die hatten richtig coole Sachen drin
und man erinnert sich heute noch dran, wie man Demervant Peak
jede Rushrunde den Damm runter gesprungen hat
das war einfach so selbstverständlich
cool eingebaut in das Game
Demervant Peak runterspringt, das hat sich nicht etwa angefühlt
als hat man das jetzt besonders
cinematic inszenieren wollen oder so
also man hat sich das natürlich dabei gedacht, aber es hat sich richtig gut eingebunden
also das war einfach nice
vor allem waren die Maps halt
ich mein, wenn man mal Grand Bazaar und Demervant Peak vergleicht
das hat nichts miteinander zu tun
und spielt sich beides trotzdem gut
wobei Grand Bazaar Rush hatte auch so seine Probleme
ja, Conquest kann man spielen
aber ich spiele Rush einfach viel lieber als Conquest
au rows
das war schön Inosgold
M".
sein 360 erst mal probiert hat.
Das ist aber auch ganz schön Glück teilweise, dass er das aus der Hüfte trifft.
Okay, die Gegner sind einfach brain dead wieder.
Ich mein, what the fuck, fahr mit dem Gegner wieder los, Alter.
Der hat sein Gamma bisschen hochgestellt, der Gute.
Du siehst ja gar nix.
Es geht nur, das liegt einfach daran, weil das die besseren Caps sind.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich bin ja 1984 geboren.
Das heißt, ich hab die volle Ladung World War II Games mitgemacht.
Alles, von Medal of Honor bis die ersten Kerle von Call of Duty bis Battlefield, alles.
Ich hab die komplette Ladung aller nur erdenklichen World War II Games mitgemacht, die ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Das heißt, mich kannst du mit World War II und solchen historischen Kriegsszenarien kannst du, das juckt mich nicht mehr.
Da kann man mich einfach nicht mehr dafür begeistern.
Ich mein, klar, man kann trotzdem ein gutes Spiel machen.
Was einen motiviert, war es halt für mich in Form von Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 auch nicht.
Aber mein Herz schlägt eindeutig für diese Art von Settings hier.
Am lieb, ich hätte ja richtig gerne mal ein Game, was wieder in der Black Ops 1 Zeit spielt.
So 80, 90 herum.
Da gibts dann so die ganzen Waffen, die man irgendwie so aus dem Spiel tut.
Da gibts MP5, hast ne AK-74, hast ne Spaßshotgun, hast ne M16, hast ne M4, hast alle AK-74-Uhr, hast alle ganzen klassischen Dinger drin.
Und ich glaube, diese Zeit könnte man auch richtig gut storymäßig oder scenariomäßig einbinden.
Da ist ja viel passiert.
So 80er, 90er, also so 80er eigentlich, bis Anfang 90er.
Da könnte man ein richtig gutes Game-Tour ausmachen.
Das ist aber eine Zeit, die mögen sie lustig, komischerweise, ich weiß nicht so genau warum, nicht so sehr in Spielen irgendwie.
Gut, es gab keine richtig großen, ausgebrochenen Konflikte, aber ich mein, dann muss ich doch nicht an die Realität halten.
Ich sag seit Jahren schon, ich sag seit Jahren schon, die sollen ein alternatives Szenario Battlefield machen.
Und ich sag auch seit Jahren schon, wisst ihr, was ne supergeile Kampagnen-Idee wäre?
Für Battlefield und vor allem für Call of Duty Singleplayer ne supergeile Kampagnen-Idee.
Sie haben ja vor ein paar Jahren angefangen mit ihrem modernen Setting und da haben die Leute gesagt, moderne Setting, Call of Duty, das wollen wir nicht.
Und jetzt sind sie wieder zurück in World of Two und jetzt sind sie wieder zurück in der Moderne.
Die sollten ne Kampagne machen, die alte Call of Duty-Kampagnen verändert.
Also die sollten so ne Multidimension-Cod-Kampagne machen.
Also sprich, wie auch immer sie das einsprechen, die sollten versuchen, mit einem Call of Duty quasi so ne Call of Duty Multiverse-Ding zu machen.
Also quasi, dass die irgendwie versuchen, alle Call of Duty-Spiele irgendwie durch so ne Parallelwelt miteinander zu verbinden.
Das hätte sehr viel Potenzial, man muss es halt gescheit machen.
Nicht unbedingt ne Zeitreise-Singleplayer-Story, sondern eher so ne Parallelwelt-Geschichte.
Das fänd ich übrigens cool, wenn sie sich irgendwas zusammenspinnen würden, wie alle Call of Duty-Spiele zusammenhängen.
Das muss nix Großartiges sein, aber das Interessante wäre, sie müssten sich aus der jeweiligen Kampagne Szenen suchen, die doppeldeutig sind.
Also sprich, Szenen suchen, wo irgendwas passiert ist, was schlecht erklärt ist.
Und ich mein, dass Dinge passieren, die schlecht erklärt sind, sind in Call of Duty-Kampagnen Standard.
Das ist normal.
Da müssten sie sich so quasi die besten Szenen raussuchen und diese Szenen müssten sie dann erklären, dadurch, dass da halt die Spieler aus dem neuesten Call of Duty mitgeholfen haben, dass sie so passiert sind.
Da könnte man so viel draus machen und das wäre auch ne coole Sache für Battlefield.
Aber gerade, weil Call of Duty so viele Singleplayer-Kampagnen hat, könnte man da richtig, richtig nice Kampagnen draus machen.
Aber das ist glaube ich zu abgedreht, das ist nicht zu, das ist nicht normal genug, das machen sie nicht.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Moin, Papi, 47.
Immer neue Fisch-KI. Fisch-KI ist aus, als nächstes kommt Vogel-KI.
Epic Accurate. Der sagt wirklich jedes Mal das Gleiche.
Und ich sag jedes Mal das Gleiche, dass er jedes Mal das Gleiche sagt.
Wenn der jetzt in dem Video erwähnen würde, dass ich jedes Mal das Gleiche über ihn sag, dass ich das Gleiche sage, dann wäre der Kreis komplett.
Deisenator Twitch Prime. Dankeschön, huge sub.
Ich seh nix.
Warum sieht der was? Nee, ich glaub da sieht er auch nix.
Warum ist ihm sein Fahnenkreuzstahl ein bisschen rot? Das wird mich übelst verwirren.
Warum liegt der da?
Was macht der da?
Der denkt sich wahrscheinlich gerade...
Ich weiß nicht, was denkt er denn was er da macht?
Ich glaub man kann davon noch nicht mal weit in den Gang gucken von da oben.
Ein wahrer Teamspieler. Das ist es, genau.
Das ist ja fast wie der Ultraskiller, der hat auch seinem Team den Rücken freigehalten.
Leute, soll ich auf den Ultraskiller reacten?
Hört mir gerade so ein, soll ich mal auf ein altes Video reacten?
Okay, kann ich nachher machen.
Dann kommt das Chrome Video.
Die Gegner schenken aber auch nicht viel, oder?
Der riecht wie ein PP-Gang-Gegner.
Money, huge points hat er ausgegeben.
Die Gegner sind so geil wieder.
Oh, da ist ein Gegner irgendwo. Was mache ich denn? Ich laufe jetzt einfach mal in dieses Fahnenkreuz von ihm.
Guck durch Tim, die Gegner sind so hohl.
Ah, jetzt hat er ihn wenigstens erwischt.
Weihnachtslubs wahrscheinlich.
Ey, ohne Mist, Hardline an sich, das reine Waffenhandling und die reinen Mechanics,
die fand ich gar nicht so schlecht in Hardline, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Keinem vom Kern war Hardline nicht schlecht.
Was mich halt überhaupt nicht angesprochen hat in Hardline, war die Spielmodi.
Die Spielmodi haben mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und die Maps waren auch teilweise merkwürdig.
Wartet mal, wir müssen mal kurz was gucken.
Battlelog Hardline.
Wir müssen mal gucken, was es da für Server noch gibt.
Ein Server, ein ganzer, okay wir sagen jetzt Free Slots, sonst spackt das Ding rum.
Okay, ne. Also es gibt einen Server, der voll ist.
Und das ist EatsRGerdAdu150, der Keltenclan.
Und den Rest spielt keiner mehr.
Conquest Large.
Ja Conquest war auch das einzige, was man in Hardline irgendwie gut spielen konnte.
Aber wie gesagt, Conquest ist ja nicht meins.
Ich fand diese Sache am Anfang gar nicht schlecht.
Wie hieß der Spielmodus, den sie in der Hardline Beta hatten?
Heißt, war das heißt?
Das war einfach zu simpel aufgebaut irgendwie.
Das war einfach zu simpel aufgebaut.
Immer exakt das Schöne an Rush ist ja, dass die Maps und Mcom Platzierungen immer gleich sind,
aber trotzdem sich jede Rush Runde ein bisschen anders spielt.
Und das war bei Heist halt überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Du hast in Heist, dass du entweder als Defender komplett die Gegner schon fast bis zum Spawn weg gebashed,
oder die Runde war in drei Minuten vorbei.
An Spielen tut es so wie es aussieht.
Guck mal, es gibt auch kaum noch Hardline Server.
Was sind das, 30 Server oder so?
30 Server und das war's.
Und die DLCs spielt natürlich kein Mensch mehr.
Guck mal, wie es bei Battlefield 4 aussieht.
Besser, viel besser.
Alle Filter, viel besser.
Guck mal, Battlefield 4 hat zumindest eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs volle Server, sieben volle Server.
Und ich meine, das ist jetzt auch nicht der Wahnsinn.
Stimmt das überhaupt, was ich da im Filter drin habe?
Guck mal, was es für Rush gibt.
Rush, ich will nur Rush.
Nur Rush.
Was gibt es für Rush?
Filter anwenden.
Ja, guck mal.
Sind das die gleichen Server wie vorher?
Oder ist die Suche gerade irgendwie kaputt?
Die Suche ist kaputt.
Leute, die Suche ist fail.
Die Suche sackt, das müssen wir nochmal neu machen.
Okay, also haken wir alles an.
Was?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Okay, also gehen wir einfach mal von aus, es spielen noch mehr Leute.
Der Filter ist irgendwie kaputt.
Leere Server aus, das ist eine gute Idee.
Wie geht denn das?
Leere Server ausblenden?
Freie Slots?
Keine.
Dann machen wir es so, also sprich alle Server, die voll sind.
Guck mal Leute, guck mal.
Das ist noch richtig gut besucht hier Battlefield 4.
Schaut mal her hier.
Das ist richtig gut besucht.
Das spielen richtig viele Leute.
So, dann machen wir das Ganze nochmal bei Battlefield Hardline.
Wir wissen jetzt ja, wie man das richtig einstellt.
Okay, keine.
Okay, das macht es nicht besser.
Also Battlefield Hardline hat jetzt anstatt einem vollen Server zwei volle Server versus irgendwie 60 oder so bei Battlefield 4.
Komm, wir gucken nochmal Battlefield 3.
Server Browser.
1 bis 5.
Refresh.
Ist auch okay.
Ich meine, wenn man sich überlegt, dass das Game ist von 2013 oder so, das ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Doch, okay.
Kann man Rush? Gibt es einen Rush-Server?
Mal angenommen, wir wollten Rush spielen.
Gibt es da noch was?
Ja, einen Rush-Server gibt es.
Und der ist aber seit Jahren schon der gleiche.
Immer der hier und die zwei.
Wie viel kostet Battlefield 3 auf dem PC?
Das gab es glaube ich mal kostenlos zwischendurch.
Aber das ist nicht teuer.
Ja, ist gut.
Was kostet das?
What? 14 Euro, das ist viel zu teuer.
Gab es das nicht auch noch auf Steam damals?
Nee.
To Origin.
Man kriegt das aber für ein Apple und ein i teilweise.
Irgendeinen Key bei einmal dem OGA oder bei den üblichen Jobs kaufen.
Es gab es doch auch mal kurzzeitig kostenlos.
Nee, das war Bad Company 2, was es kurzzeitig kostenlos gab.
Man kriegt es für 3 Euro oder so. 3, 4 Euro.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Das coole war, dass man glaube ich in Hardline wieder halbwegs Gegner durchsprayen konnte.
Ja, weil es kein normales Game war mit Server-Software und allem, sondern mit ME2 haben sie angefangen ihren Bullshit da zu machen.
Mit P2P-Hosting und vor allem keine Server mehr, die man installieren konnte und kein Modding-Support und nichts.
Das hat in Hardline wirklich Spaß gemacht, aber für mich ist Bad Company 2 bei Battlefield 3 gefolgt von Battlefield 4.
Die Gegner mit der Viennisch-Gamecheck.
Denkst du MW2 Remastered wird kommen? Ich glaube persönlich nicht daran.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie MW2 Remastered machen aus dem Grund, weil das aktuelle Game auch wieder Modern Warfare heißt.
Das ist jetzt schon komplett fucked up, also komplett für den Arsch die Benamung.
Aber wenn jetzt gerade Modern Warfare aktuell ist und die würden jetzt Modern Warfare 2 Remastered rausbringen,
Leute, da blickt wirklich keiner mehr durch. Das werden die nicht machen.
Ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, nachdem sich das aktuelle Game ja wohl ziemlich gut verkauft hat
und aus Gründen, die sich mir nicht komplett erschließen, auch viele Leute das Game gut finden,
dass es ein Modern Warfare 2 Reboot, also dass es ein Modern Warfare 2019 2 gibt.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Also ein neues Modern Warfare 2,
was mit dem Modern Warfare früher nichts zu tun haben, sondern mit dem aktuellen Modern Warfare.
Was sagst du zum Cod Battle Royale League Shitstorm? Das ist mir vollkommen egal.
Ich werde es dafür auch nicht mehr installieren.
Battle Royale war eh, guck mal, das aktuelle Cod hat bei mir eh nicht so richtig gezündet.
Und Battle Royale ist eh überhaupt nicht so meins. Warum soll ich dann gerade diese 2 Sachen in Kombination mich da wieder zubringen?
Und angeblich soll es ja Free to Play werden, also habe ich geleakt gelesen irgendwo.
After Battlefield 5 has come out as well, it kind of made Battlefield 1 look a lot better or even better than it already was.
Weil Apex Legends gezogen, nee. Das ist aber das einzige Battle Royale Game, was ich gerne gucke auf Twitch.
Also für mich ist es das schönste Battle Royale Game. Also nicht optisch, sondern generell vom Flow und von allem.
Mir fällt das rein, ich kann es ja nur aus Zuschauerperspektive sagen, ist das für mich das beste Battle Royale Game.
Ich weiß, dass viele Hardcore-Pros irgendwie flamen, das Game hätte zu wenig Tiefgang.
Keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt. In der Regel haben Games mit schnellem und vertikanem Movement schon eigentlich fast noch ein bisschen mehr Tiefgang.
Weiß nicht, was da dran ist, aber rein zum Zugucken ist mir das mein Lieblings Battle Royale Game.
Jetzt in den Bobs.
Chat.
Das ist auch eine der Punkte, die mir an Battlefield 1 persönlich jetzt nicht ganz so gut gefallen haben, ist,
ich habe immer gerne Medic gespielt, schon in allen Battlefield-Teilen. Irgendwie haben die Medic-Waffen bei mir nicht so hundertprozentig gezündet.
Die haben sich zwar ganz gut angefühlt vom Impact her, aber man kann diese halbautomatischen Dinger doch schlecht vergleichen mit so einer M16 oder sowas.
Da geht es einfach mehr ab. Ja, und ich weiß, dass es noch viele weitere Waffen gegeben hat, die ich wahrscheinlich nie gesehen habe, weil ich das Game nicht lang gespielt habe.
Das fand ich in Battlefield 3, 4 und Hardline auch das Geile. Wenn du hier so einen guten Flank gemacht hast in Battlefield 3, nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal Battlefield 3.
Wenn du so einen Flank gemacht hast in Battlefield 3, die 3 wären innerhalb von 3 bis 4 Sekunden weg. Und hier hat man gar nicht genug Schuss dafür.
Wobei, den hätte er auch... Moment, man kriegt 21 Schuss in dieses Ding rein? Kriegt man da am Anfang nicht... Hä? Die Waffen, an die ich mich erinnern kann mit dem Medic, die hatten irgendwie 8 Schuss oder so.
Warum hat der 21 Schuss auf einmal? Erklärt mir das mal als Battlefield 1 Noob. Warum hat der so viel Schuss?
Nein, ohne Scheiß. Am Anfang, die Medic Waffen, die haben 8 Schuss oder so gehabt. Ja, aber was ist denn das für eine bescheuerte Balance, wenn es Waffen mit 8 Schuss gibt, die halt ähnlich viel Damage machen wie Waffen mit 21 Schuss? Das ist ja komplett geklackt.
Retarded oder so Schüsse, alles. Gut, aber Battlefield und Balance ist ja eh so eine Sache. Die Battlefield-Dinger waren 2-Shots. Ja, aber mehr Schuss trotzdem besser.
Weil du triffst ja in Battlefield bei dem ganzen Rumgewackele der Gegner, also dieses unpredicke Rumgewackele, was beim Rennen teilweise auftritt. Du triffst ja 2 Schüsse, gar nicht wirklich konsistent, es sei denn dein Typ steht direkt vor dir.
Guckt euch das an, die Gegner wackeln. Das ist dieses typische Battlefield-Movement-Gewackel, wo du halt teilweise echt Probleme hast, was zu hippen. Guck, guck hier, der läuft gerade aus, jetzt ist er auf einmal da.
Jetzt auf einmal, what the fuck? Okay, der Typ hat auch ziemlich über-aimed gerade, aber trotzdem, Battlefield-Movement hat teilweise ganz schön vieles, so interpoliertes Rumgewackel dabei. Das kann durchaus sein, dass einer vor dir ist und du schießt halt 3 Schüsse, 1 von 3 vorbei.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich der Chat, jetzt fehlt irgendwie noch einer, der ankommt. Gitgut, oder irgendwie sowas.
Das Line war richtig krasse. Melee-Gameplay? Ich finde, naja, okay. Melee-Gameplay weiß ich auch mal, dass man das unbedingt braucht in Battlefield.
Wurde dann richtig genervt. Gitgut ist noch Gitgoman. Oh fuck, stimmt, jetzt wurde es das. Könnt ihr euch noch an den krassen Shitstorm erinnern?
Vom ersten Battlefield 5 Trailer, wo die das Haus gestürmt haben und auf einmal stand dann oben ein schwarzer Soldat mit einem Katana auf dem Rücken und dann ist man runtergefallen und dann kam diese Frau mit der Kralle.
Boi, die Güte war da ein Shitstorm angesagt, ey. Aber sie haben es ja auch selbst verkackt. Sie können sich ja nicht als Intro zu so einem Trailer hinstellen, 20 Minuten lang, und erzählen, dass sie mit Historikern zusammengearbeitet haben.
Und quasi versuchen, so die versteckten Geschichten aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg zu erzählen und sie sich halt an Most Immersive Realistic und bla bla bla bla bla bla halten.
Und dann zeigen sie einen Trailer mit einem schwarzen Soldat mit einem Katana auf dem Rücken und eine Frau mit einer Kralle an der Hand.
Ah, das hätte ihnen doch selbst einleuchten müssen, dass das vielleicht keine allzu gute Kombination ist nach dem Intro. Hätte man gesagt, ich sage es ja schon lange, hätten die gesagt, das ist nicht Zweiter Weltkrieg, sondern das ist alternative Realität Zweiter Weltkrieg.
So keine Ahnung, die Russen haben den Zweiten Weltkrieg angefangen, irgendwas, hätten sie irgendwas anderes ausgedacht, dann wäre das vollkommen okay gewesen, weil da hätte man sagen können, okay, es soll ja nicht historisch sein, es ist quasi abgewandelte Geschichte.
Dann hätte keiner was gesagt, aber man kann sich doch nicht 20 Minuten hinstellen und vorher 20 Minuten rumschwadrunieren bla bla bla wie Realistic und sonst was und dann kommt das.
Aber was ist, was genau ist eigentlich gerade mit den Gegnern los? Kann mir das mal einer erklären? Was, was, was, was ist, was, was? Ich, mir fällt da gerade gar nichts dazu ein. Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Komplette Braindead-Gegner, na-aim, ppega-aim, genau, so sieht es aus.
Moving on to Battlefield V, the final game that we're going to be taking a look at in today's episode EN98 and some satisfying sniping clips. Absolutely epic, how accurate this guy is.
Ist das jetzt eins oder ist das fünf? Ich glaube, der hat es gerade gesagt, aber ich habe nicht zugehört. Fünf? Ich finde es mittlerweile echt schlimm, wie ähnlich die ganzen Sachen aussehen.
Das war cool, das war ein richtig guter Clip. Was für ein Ding.
Warum sieht ihn der Panzer da vorne nicht?
Haha, der ist voll reingerannt. Voll mit dem Kopf in den Revolver reingerannt.
Leave a like if you enjoyed, feel free to leave a dislike if you didn't and I'll catch you in the next episode.
Rückschuss hat das Ding anscheinend nicht. Rückschuss overrated, jebaited. Ich habe den Eindruck, ich habe ja wie gesagt Battlefield V habe ich so gut wie nicht gespielt. Ich habe den Eindruck, das erste Mal bei Gameplay, was ich sehe, wo wirklich Battlefield Feeling aufkommt, ist das letzte, dieses Pacific Addon.
Wie geht es euch da so? Also ich bin ja reiner Zuschauer bei Battlefield V und ich hatte bei allem, was ich gesehen habe, von Battlefield V nie das Gefühl, ich sitze da vor einem Battlefield, was ich nach Battlefield anfühlt und aussieht.
Das erste Mal, dass ich bei Battlefield V dieses Gefühl beim Zugucken habe, ist mit diesem Pacific Addon.
Nur das hier, das sieht halt einfach mal nach Battlefield aus.
Was für ein hässliches Ding. Wie eine Panzerfaust oder so.
Der Gold Skin, frage mal an die Leute, die sich damit auskennen. Der Gold Skin, wie unlockt man den? Ist das Pay to Win Box? Ist das Challenges in Game? Ist das, wie kriegt man das? Einfach nur viel Waffe spielen?
Es spielen? Okay.
Ich habe das Gefühl, keiner hittet ihn.
Schau mal, wer kennt es nicht erstmal mittendrinne Stats checken.
Hard Copy Pegas, Hard Copy Pegas, Hard Copy Pegas. Da ist noch was dahinter, sonst hätte er nichts gehitted, genau.
Jetzt ist er wahrscheinlich gestorben, sonst hätte es das gezeigt.
Ich hätte echt Bock drauf, dass sie ein neues Battlefield machen. Im Geiste von Bad Company 2, aber es gab ja Gerüchte, Bad Company 3 ist in Entwicklung und jetzt gibt es ja Gerüchte, dass sie Gerüchte haben, dass Battlefield Bad Company 3 eingestellt wurde, aber wissen tut man nichts.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5? Das erste ist der 1. Weltkrieg, das andere ist der 2. Weltkrieg. Kannst du das nicht direkt anhand des Namens des Spiels erkennen?
Ist doch ganz klar, dass Battlefield 1 im ersten Weltkrieg spielt und Battlefield 5 natürlich im zweiten Weltkrieg. Ist doch logisch. Die Benamung ist mittlerweile so im Arsch.
Ich frage mich was als nächstes kommt. Ich weiß was als nächstes kommt. Als nächstes gibt es einfach nur Battlefield. Das ist doch jetzt auch im Trend, dass man einfach bei Spielen alles weglässt. Als nächstes kommt nur Battlefield.
Wenn die nächstes Jahr ein neues Battlefield raus ist, dann heißt es einfach nur Battlefield. Die müssen die Leute maximal verwirren. Und ich glaube mit Battlefield, was nur Battlefield hieß, gab es noch nicht.
Weil sogar das erste Battlefield hieß 1942. Und eins gab es auch schon, aber es gab noch nie einfach nur Battlefield. Jetzt gucken wir an als nächstes.
In den TED Talk gucken wir jetzt nicht. Die gucke ich auch mittlerweile immer gern. Der Typ der die Schlösser knackt. Ah der Ultra. Ah Moment. Ich muss ja Ultrascaler reacten. Hab ich schon wieder ganz vergessen.
Das wird hardcore cringe werden auf mein eigenes Video zu reacten. Ich sag's euch.
Die Audio-Quali. Alter die Audio-Quali. Die Audio-Quali.
Und ich muss jetzt schon sagen, das ist der beste Spieler mit dem ich jetzt zusammen gespielt habe. Der hat unglaubliche Map-Kenntnis. Der ist, ich kann es dir ganz gar nicht beschreiben. Der wusste einfach immer das Richtige.
Oh dieser ist das aus dem letzten Jahrtausend. Ja fast. Fast von 2011. Belegt euch mal das Video ist fast genau neun Jahre alt. Kann man sich das vorstellen? Neun Jahre alt ist der Scheiß schon.
Was man machen muss. Guck hier. Allein schon wie geil der die Flagge erobert. Und jetzt hier. Bam. Jetzt sitzt er einfach. Jetzt setzt er sich einfach hin. Ich wusste dass ich irgendwie sowas gesagt habe. Das zeugt von großer Aufopferung für das Team.
Das Team. Warte mal. Für 2011 ist das auch nicht schlecht. Ich glaub da hatte ich schon mein Ploieti am Start. Ich hab's einfach total zu laut eingestellt. Deswegen hab ich übersteuert.
Da setzt er sich einfach hin. Das zeugt von großer Aufopferung für das Team. Der stellt seine eigenen Kills zurück und campt an der C Flagge. Der Typ. Der hat als Klasse kann ich schon mal verraten.
Kommando mit Granatwerfer. Das zeugt allein schon mal von hohem Spielverständnis und Können. Danach hat er Second Chance Pro. Die Teamplayer Perk. Die Teamplayer Perk. Ich hab ja versucht ihn unkenntlich zu machen hier. Aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Man sieht den Namen trotzdem irgendwo.
Wie hieß der Taga Taga Tlaga Tlaga oder irgendwie so. Das bin ich. Ich hab nicht verstanden was er da macht. Bis ich irgendwann diese gottgleiche Taktik verstanden hab. Die er verfolgt. Dann hab ich ihn auch in Ruhe gelassen. Weil ich gedacht hab boah dass ich mal mit so jemanden zusammen spielen kann. Das ist außergewöhnlich.
Da ist der Fabian noch oder? Ist es der Friseur der hier mit rumspringt? Unbedingt auf Video festhalten. Dass ich mir das immer wieder angucken kann wenn ich mal grad zacke. Dass ich mir sagen kann. Siste es gibt Leute die können das Spiel tatsächlich gut spielen. Jetzt hab ich's verstanden jetzt geh ich weg.
Ach ne die Sylvana ist das. Die Sylvana ist das. Also der hat's extrem drauf. Vor allem dieses reingezoomt bleiben auf die C-Fahne. Dass man möglichst viel von der Umgebung sieht. Das ist wahres Können. Wahres Können.
Ich hab jetzt das Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte. Dass wahres Können halt relativ langweilig anzuschauen ist. Der Typ ist mega konzentriert. Der ist mega konzentriert. Gleich komm da gleich komm da. Ich will mindestens ein Kill machen.
Lebt der Friseur noch? Klar der streamt sogar manchmal noch. Irgendwelche Mobile Games grade. Ja aber das ist der größte hier mit dem ich je gespielt hab. Die tatsächlich gar nicht so noobstyle aussehen wie man es denkt aber Mobile Games da fang ich das gar nicht mit an. Ich muss den Friseur überreden dass wir das Amazon MMO ausprobieren.
Wahnsinn. Man sieht es vielleicht auf der Minimap. Wir kloppen uns gerade um die B-Fahne. Aber es juckt dir nicht. Aber er wie gesagt ganz Teamplayer durch und durch. Er macht einfach nichts. Er versucht keine Kills zu machen nichts.
Das geile ist das haben mir ganz viele Leute geglaubt damals ne. Also wenn ihr die Kommentare durchgeht da sind dann wirklich Leute dabei die haben das geglaubt und sagen dann sag dir mal du also Max ehrlich so gut ist er jetzt auch wieder nicht.
Das ist einfach C. Und das ist wirklich wahres Können. Ich kann den einfach nicht genug loben. Geht gar nicht. Ich bin jetzt wenn ich mir das angucke ich bin in tiefer Ehrfurcht von dieser Leistung schon. Vor allem wenn es der Gegner doch tatsächlich mal schaffen sollte ihn mit mindestens 5 Spielern auf einmal zu killen.
Er hatte immer noch 2nd Chance und damit wird er sie alle wegbashen noch. Geht gar nicht anders. Also mit diesem. Ich weiß gar nicht wie ich mir die ganzen Blödsinn aus den Fingern saugen konnte weil es passiert ja nichts.
Spieler im Team. Mit diesem Spieler im Team kann man nicht verlieren. Sieht man auch schon unten. 44 29. Er hat sehr viel dazu beigetragen. Das versteht ihr vielleicht nicht. Ihr sagt jetzt hm der ist so dumm der kämpft nur an der C-Fahne. Nein das ist falsch. Das ist falsch.
Der kämpft nicht an der C-Flage. Wir sind einfach nur woanders. Er ist an der richtigen Stelle. Er weiß wie das Spiel funktioniert. Er weiß wo man sein muss. Und wir sind einfach falsch. Das müssen alle mal verstehen die dieses Video gucken.
Jeder der jetzt sagt der Typ kann nicht spielen. Der Typ ist schlecht oder so. Der hat keine Ahnung. Der macht es richtig. Der kämpft an der C-Flage. So wird es gemacht. Und nicht wie wir einfach immer sinnlos uns da bashen lassen. Das war zu hoch vor YouTube. Das haben mir so viele Leute geglaubt.
Er bewegt sich. Ja klar sonst wird er wegen Inaktivität gekickt. Der Typ der hat eine grandiose. Aber ich sag's euch er bewegt er bewegt sich tatsächlich gleich. KD. Der hat eine KD die kann man aktuell noch nicht mal errechnen. Eine KD von 0 zu 0. Wer von euch hat eine KD von 0 zu 0?
Borgas. Das geht doch gar nicht. Das geht einzig und allein durch Leadnes, Brones durch und durch. So wie dieser Spieler hier. Er hat Steps gehört. Genau. Ja mich hat er gehört. Wie gesagt ich befinde mich ja schon grad in tiefer Demut vor ihm und möchte ihm dadurch meine Hochachtung zollen dass ich hier auf ihn schieße.
Und hat den Motto ja ich verstehe wenn du zurückschießen würdest wäre ich instant tot. Und das weiß er. Das versteht er. Das hat er wohlwollend auch zur Kenntnis genommen. Das sieht man hier auch. Er bewegt sich immer mal kurz. Gleich bewegt er sich. Man muss dazusagen. Der ist so schnell im reagieren. Der muss sich gar nicht bewegen. Der Gegner kommt nur mit einem Pixel ins Bild. Bam. Guck hier. Guck es euch an hier. Bam. Quickscope. Bam. Kaputt ist er. Chancenlos der Gegner. Chancenlos. Richtig dumm ey. Und der nächste gleich hier.
Da ist Achtung hier. Bam. Huge Reactions. Sie brauchen fünf Gegner um den Typ zu baschen. So hart oder. Und vor allem er ist noch nicht tot. Aber noch Second Chance. Und mit Second Chance geht der Dritter erst richtig auf. Gleich kommt es hier. Achtung. Guck mal hier. Jetzt hier. Bam. Erster Gegner. Zweiter Gegner. Dritter Gegner. Alle kaputt. Bam. Bam. Komplettes Team ausgeräuchert in Second Chance. So geht es. So. Schaut es euch mal an.
Schaut euch mal ab von dem hier. Die Sylvaner. Die Sylvaner hat ihn auch noch wiederbelebt. Und hat eine Kd von 2 zu 0. So geht es. So geht es. Von solchen Kds träumt man normalerweise nur.
Weil man eine Kd von 2 zu 0 immer noch nicht ausrechnen kann. Ist ja wichtig. 2 geteilt durch 0 ist geht nicht. Oder ist nicht definiert. Der weiß einfach wie es geht. Was ist da oben? Der hat das Spiel kaputt. Was ist da oben? Wenn das alle machen würden wird das abstürzen.
Ja. Kippt dann hier. Fehler. Jetzt ist ja schon wieder ganzes Team. Ganzes Team stürzt sich auf ihn und er stirbt. Hat er sich bestimmt geärgert jetzt. Aber er versucht natürlich gleich wieder zur C-Flage zu kommen.
Der will wieder an den gleichen Spot. Man sieht es hier einfach. Die brauchen ein komplettes Team um ihn zu killen. Und in dieser Zeit können wir ohne Probleme die anderen Fahnen erobern.
Wisst ihr was das geile ist? Wir gewinnen auch noch haushoch. Also das waren die übelsten Bäger Gegner überhaupt anscheinend.
Das ist nämlich die wahre Taktik. Der ist so spielstark. Der zieht das ganze gegnerische Team auf sich. Und währenddessen können wir die Fahnen erobern. Deswegen macht er nicht mit Fahnen erobern. Ganz einfach.
Wahrscheinlich spielt er auch wieder Commander Krieger so dominant, dass er nackt spielen muss. Aber ich weiß es nicht. Aber der ist schon... Guck dir dieses Aiming an.
Huge Aiming. Das kann man schon gar nicht mehr Aiming nennen. Das ist schon hart am Aimbot eigentlich. Wobei der nicht... Der cheatet nicht. Das kann ich jetzt schon sagen. Der ist einfach nur so gut.
Der ist nur so gut. Genau. Schon wieder im ganzen Team auf sich gestürzt. In der Zeit haben wir es geschafft die Fahnen zu erobern. Oh jetzt hat er einen. Jetzt hat er zwei.
Das ist wahre Teamplayer. Und jetzt macht er etwas sehr Intelligentes. Jetzt kommt ein Move gleich. Den habe ich so noch nie gesehen. Den traue ich auch nur den ganz wenigsten...
Der verpetzt das Spiel ab....MG Pros und sonst was zu. Diesen Move den er jetzt hier gleich macht.
Das war Claymore. Guckt euch an. Die Claymore vor den Tisch zu stellen sodass sie nicht auslöst. Das ist... Ja.
Und der sieht den natürlich. Der will den einschüchtern. Oh.
Das können wir jetzt überspringen. Der nächste Tapart ist übelst langweilig. Da ist meine Xbox abgekackt.
Ich muss erstmal wieder ins Game und vorspulen.
Verständlich. Sehr verständlich.
Denn ihr wisst ja Ziel des Spiels ist ja Flaggen zu halten.
Warum ist der Kill vizenziert? Weil ich nicht wollte dass die Leute ihn flamen.
Aber ich habe nicht richtig aufgepasst. Man sieht seinen Namen trotzdem irgendwo.
Da sieht er natürlich. Der hätte ihn sofort gekillt. Er versucht ihn einzuschüchtern um ihn wegzutreiben von der A-Flagge.
Denn ihr wisst ja Ziel des Spiels ist ja Flaggen zu halten. Deswegen ist es sinnlos die Gegner zu killen.
Was hat der eigentlich für eine Sense an seinem Controller eingestellt? Guckt euch das mal an.
Wo ich vorhin gesagt habe, da sieht er natürlich. Der hätte ihn sofort gekillt. Er versucht ihn einzuschüchtern um ihn wegzutreiben von der A-Flagge.
Guckt euch mal an wie der jetzt gleich mit dem Nuke-Druck-Bomb ballert.
Was hat der für eine Sense? Das sinnvollste ist die Gegner einzuschüchtern, dass sie nicht zur Flagge kommen.
Das praktiziert er hier in Perfektion.
Dieser Spielzug jetzt ist sogar mir zu hoch. Ich verstehe nicht was er macht. Aber es wird schon sehr durchdacht sein.
Die Gegner kommen alle nicht her. Keiner traut sich an ihn ran.
Die müssen erst mal mit dem ganzen Team außen rumflanken, dass das überhaupt klappt.
Sieben Schüsse vom gegnerischen Team. Jeder schießt 20 Mal und dann stirbt er. Er ist immer noch nicht tot. Guckt euch an.
Und in der Zeit, wo das ganze Team sich um ihn gekümmert hat, haben wir B erobert.
So kann es wirklich gehen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich euch die Taktik von ihm näher bringen kann. Denn mir ist die Taktik auch zu hoch.
Ich werde nie auf diesem Level spielen können und ich wette einfach mal viele von euch, nein, alle von euch, werden nie dahin kommen, wo der schon ist.
Das ist jahrzehntelange Shooter-Erfahrung. Der hat schon Shooter auf dem Gameboy gespielt. Nur dann kann man so gut sein.
Guckt, das war ich wieder neben. Pure Huldigung an ihn.
Und jetzt haben sie sich da drüben, das gesamte gegnerische Team, wieder drüben verschanzt, nur um ihn zu töten.
Und man sieht oben bei C, wir können C erobern.
Sag mal, wie schlecht müssen die Gegner eigentlich sein, dass wir so haushoch gewinnen mit so einem Typ im Team?
Ich habe ein Video zu Milch ist Gift gemacht, da muss ich gleich mal gucken, da weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Da sieht man, man muss mal Pause machen. Man sieht jetzt auch mal seine Klasse, die beste Zusammenstellung überhaupt.
Ich zeig dir jetzt mal, ich drücke mal Pause.
Flag Jacket ist wichtig.
Richtiges Pepega-Loadout, Alter.
Das wird viel aushalten.
Richtiges Pepega-Loadout.
Wenn man das im ganzen Team aufnehmen muss, ist viel aushalten wichtig.
Slide of Hand Pro, sonst wäre sein Wahnsinns-Aim gar nicht möglich.
Sein Aimbot-mäßiger Aim.
Und Second Chance Pro.
Second Chance Pro, das zeigt...
Ich tendiere noch, eventuell hätte man so diese Klasse statt Flag Jacket, sage ich jetzt einfach mal in meiner Unwissenheit,
hätte man vielleicht noch Ghost Pro nehmen können.
Statt Flag Jacket.
Allerdings maße ich mir gar nicht erst an, über seine Klassenwahl hier zu spekulieren.
Und hier diese Ecke, die kannte ich noch gar nicht.
Kannte dir diese Ecke. Wahnsinn.
Huge Ecke.
Der deckt ja komplett neue Bereiche in dieser Map auf.
Big Brain.
Die mir absolut unerschlossen und unbekannt waren bisher.
Unglaublich. Unglaublich.
Und dieser Kasten da, wer weiß was da drin ist, das weiß nur er.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, Post.
Dieses Move, dieses elegante Raubkatze-artige Move.
Hat sich einen Scheiß erzählen lassen.
Und jetzt, jawohl, wer? Geschafft.
Easy Win. Easy Win.
Wir haben gewonnen, einzig und allein wegen ihm.
Ich danke nochmal, dass ich mit dir zusammenspielen durfte.
Und in tiefer Demut verabschiede ich mich. Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Matchup.
Was ein Schwachsinn Video, Alter.
Aber wie das 274.000 Aufruf war, einfach nur.
Der denkt sich nur genau, das denkt er sich jetzt.
Egal.
Aber wisst ihr, was das Video von mir war, was die wenigsten, also zur damaligen Zeit, ja.
Also sag mal so, wenn man was sagt und nicht so meint, checken die Leute auf YouTube eh nicht.
Killerspiel MW3.
Das haben die wenigsten Leute gecheckt.
Das da.
Hallo meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren.
Das haben die Leute nicht gecheckt.
Und guck mal hier, ein Kart Negative Modes, wo sich die Leute übelst drüber aufgeregt haben.
Ich hab das so voll auf seriös gemacht, dass das halt das ganz böses Killerspiel ist und man das irgendwie seinen Kindern nicht geben soll oder sowas.
Und die Leute haben es nicht gecheckt.
Die Leute haben es nicht gecheckt, Alter.
Das haben die...
Ich mein allein schon, wenn ich so anfange, oder?
Hallo meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren.
Ich begrüße Sie zu meinem ersten Video.
Das haben die Leute dann halt nicht gecheckt.
So dumm.
Und was, ich hab ein Video gemacht zur Milch ist Gift.
Ernsthaft?
Ach das.
Zentralrat der Kekse klärt auf.
Genau.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Hier ist der Max.
Und heute bin ich im Auftrag der Wahrheit unterwegs.
Und zwar geht es darum, dass ich mich zutiefst persönlich beleidigt und angegriffen fühle durch das neue Video über Milch von Uge.
Ganz schlimm.
Und nachdem ich dann bekannt dafür bin, dass ich die besten Reaction und Prank Videos auf YouTube mache, dachte ich mir, da bin ich gerade der Richtige zu jetzt mal was zu sagen zu diesem Thema.
Und zwar warum ich mich so beleidigt fühle.
Denn ich würde mich sogar auf mehreren Ebenen gleich beleidigt.
Hochgradig beleidigt. Auf drei Ebenen.
Das erste ist, ich fühle mich persönlich als Keks beleidigt.
Ich fühle mich als FPS beleidigt.
Und ich fühle mich leider, und soweit ist es mittlerweile schon gekommen, auch als 33-jähriger heterosexueller Omnivore-Weißer beleidigt.
Oh je, Max.
Gefährlich.
Gefährlich ganz dünnes Eis, Max.
Ganz dünnes Eis.
Dass ich euch jetzt einfach mal die Wahrheit erzähle, was hier los ist.
Triggert.
Und außerdem bin ich froh, dass ich mich auch mal auflegen kann.
Und widmen wir uns jetzt mal den absolut hochstrandalösen Inhalten von diesem Video.
Als erstes ist es die Ernährungspyramide, ja.
Also es ist mir jetzt egal, ob das die kanadische Ernährungspyramide ist oder die nichtkanadische Ernährungspyramide.
Ich würde an der Stelle übrigens gerne mal die Ernährungspyramide von Uganda sehen, auf der Nakels oder eben.
Oh Gott, das war ein schlechter Witz.
Ich würde dich gerne mal nehmen.
Die Uganda Ernährungspyramide.
Das war schon, das war schon, das ist, da bewegt man sich ja auf YouTube mittlerweile auf einem ganz dünnen Eis, wo man so ein Blödsinn von sich gibt.
Die schlimmste an dieser Ernährungspyramide für mich ist, dass da keine Kekse drauf sind.
Und das kann nicht sein, ja.
Das beleidigt mich zutiefst.
Und dass auch keine Frames drauf sind.
Weil ich meine, das ist mittlerweile hinlänglich bekannt und wissenschaftlich bewiesen.
Da müssen wir uns nicht irgendwie diskutieren oder so.
Da muss mir keiner ankommen und sagen, Max, das stimmt nicht, Max, das ist falsch.
Das ist mittlerweile wissenschaftlich bewiesen.
Und ich hab's auch in so vielen Videos schon gesagt, dass das menschliche Auge mittlerweile...
Oh Gott, jetzt kommt wieder dieses Thema.
Fakt, ja.
Das menschliche Auge sieht 12 Frames pro Sekunde.
Das heißt, mit zwei Augen hat man einen natürlichen Verbrauch von 24 Frames pro Sekunde.
Demnach ist der natürliche Vorrat von FPS sehr schnell aufgebraucht.
Und kann nur durch Kekse wieder aufgefüllt werden.
Das ist ansonsten nicht möglich.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das nicht in irgendwelchen Ernährungspyramiden berüstet sich weh.
Ich verstehe das einfach.
Ich kann mich an das Video überhaupt nicht mehr erinnern.
Und es ist auch mittlerweile...
Es ist einfach klar, ja?
Es ist auch komplett klar, ja?
Künstlich hergestellte FPS sind letztens...
Das ist eigentlich voll dämlich, ja?
In einer Studie von meinem sehr fairen Kollegen und geschätzten Kollegen,
Herrn Christian Pfeiffer vom Themonologischen Forschungsinstitut Niedersachsen
gab es wieder eine Studie dazu, dass künstlich hergestellte FPS sind nur halb so effektiv
wie natürlich gebildete FPS.
Muss ich euch mal vorstellen. Halb so effektiv.
Und das nächste...
Das Gameplay ist aber gut, ja?
...in der Ernährungspyramide ist auch wieder ein Punkt, wo ich mich total drüber aufregen könnte.
Körperliche Aktivität.
Es ist ja nur mittlerweile erwiesen.
Da müssen wir auch nicht mehr großartig drüber rumdiskutieren, ja?
Und falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, dann sage ich es euch hier.
Es ist erwiesen, dass körperliche Aktivität zu schwersten,
zu absolut schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden führen kann, ja?
Das ist wie das Verwenden einer Tastatur.
Wer mal auf alte Microsoft-Tastaturen draufguckt, da steht auch Stand für.
Auf jeder Tastatur drauf.
Das Verwenden einer Tastatur kann zu schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden führen, ja?
Das ist so. Stand wirklich drauf.
Auf die zweite Seite vom Handbuch, wo das gestanden hat,
natürlich vor allem im Zusammenhang mit Omnivore-Ernährung.
Also wenn man Tastaturen...
Die Überleitung war gut.
...verwendet, plus sich während dem Verwenden einer Tastatur noch Omnivore ernährt.
Das ist der Teufel. Das ist ganz, ganz schrecklich, ja?
Das ist alles hochgefährlich. Das fördert alles, ja?
Omnivore-Ernährung.
Die Kontanz kann sogar bis zu Blut am Euter führen.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen durch das Verwenden einer Tastatur.
Eieieiei.
Also ich empfehle...
Oh man, was ein Stumpfsinn, Alter.
...wenn mich jemand danach fragt, und das geht mir ja heute in diesem Video auch ein bisschen so...
Blut am Euter.
...zu bringen.
Also ich empfehle täglich, anstatt körperliche Aktivität, täglich mindestens...
Oh, das tut ja schon weh beim Zugucken.
...20 bis 30 Minuten Aim-Map zu trainieren, ja?
Und ich fordere an dieser Stelle auch, weil es kann nicht sein,
dass es in unseren Schulen komplett durchs Raste rutscht und komplett nicht vertreten ist.
Oh ne, Leute, ich kann es mir nicht weiter angucken.
Ich kann es mir nicht weiter angucken.
Leichte Cringe-Anfälle gibt es ja schon, wenn ich mir das Video angucke.
Ich kann solche Videos auch nur aufnehmen,
wenn ich mich in der passenden, geistigen Verfassung dazu befinde.
Das geht nicht. Ich kann nicht von jetzt auf gleich sowas...
Guck mal, wer da am Start ist hier.
Ich kann nicht sowas von jetzt auf gleich aufnehmen.
Das muss passend sein.
Oh man, was...
Es wird mal wieder Zeit für ein Video, würde ich sagen, oder?
Leute, wenn ich mir das angucke, schaut mal her.
Das letzte Video ist...
Drei Monate her.
Drei Monate.
Kann man sich das vorstellen? Drei Monate her.
Aber dafür habe ich davor zwei, drei Monate richtig viele Videos gespammt.
Hier war ich richtig aktiv, Leute.
Hier war ich richtig aktiv.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 12, 18, 24, 30 Videos in zweieinhalb Monaten.
Das war für mich ein Huge-Spiel.
Und danach hatte ich wieder keinen Bock mehr.
Aber es ist ja nichts Neues. Davor ja auch nicht.
Guck hier, vor fünf Monaten, vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr, da habe ich mal wieder viel gemacht.
Da habe ich mal wieder viel gemacht.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Das schwankt halt bei mir immer so, ne?
Dann lad doch einfach die Streams... Nee, die Streams haben auf YouTube nichts zu suchen.
Das guckt keiner.
Zu viel. Zu lange.
So, okay, weiter. Was haben wir denn jetzt noch zu gucken?
Switch for Linux. Ist Linux Better Gaming OS for... Nein.
Nein ist es nicht.
Linux ist, egal mit welcher CPU, kein ordentliches Gaming OS.
Warum versuchen das die Leute immer so hinzudrehen?
Ich verdiene mein Geld mit Linux.
Ich könnte... Ich würde kein Geld... Wenn es Linux nicht gäbe, würde ich kein Geld verdienen.
Aber jemand, der seit 15 Jahren Linux benutzt, seit... Nein, vielleicht.
Doch, doch.
Seit 13 Jahren Linux verwendet,
der sein Geld mit Linux verdient,
der privat fast alles unter Linux macht, was unter Linux zu machen geht,
sage ich euch, Linux ist kein gutes Gaming Betriebssystem.
Weil es einfach keine ordentlichen Games dafür gibt.
Und wenn es Games dafür gibt, dann sind es halt die Minderheit.
Also wenige, wenige Games.
Wenn es da mal eins dafür gibt, native, ist es gut.
Und dann läuft es auch, aber es gibt halt wenige.
Und die ganzen Zusatztechniken, die es da so gibt...
Wir gucken uns das einfach mal an.
Wir gucken uns das einfach mal an, was der uns erzählen will.
Ob das Better... Besseres Gaming OS ist.
Aus Sellout.
Gehört das jetzt noch zur Ad oder geht das Video schon los?
Wie nutzt du Linux privat in der VM? Ja, ich benutze das hier.
Da ist es. Da ist unser Linux für den Stream.
Stream VM. Da ist es.
Ich habe keinen Bock zu rebooten.
Und es ist deutlich einfacher, Linux unter Windows zu verwenden,
als Windows unter Linux.
Deswegen habe ich Windows für Video, Streaming, Spiele und alles.
Und Linux in der VM umgedreht funktioniert das nicht so gut.
Und dann wurde Ryzen ein Ding und, naja, schau dir das an.
Und Video dominiert...
Aber Baby, es verbessert sich dort.
Oh, wow. Schau dir das an.
Und until es geht...
Oh nein.
So far, Microsoft hat sich ziemlich bewusst
über ihre gefährliche Position als Solz für ein operiertes System.
Und sie publizieren z.B. eine Menge ihrer eigenen Spiele auf Plattformen
außerhalb der Microsoft-Store.
Was geht da los?
Nicht zu erwähnen, dass es sehr einfach ist, sie zu verwenden.
Nicht zu erwähnen, dass es z.B.
optimiert ist, für weniger Forschung.
Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass ich mich auf die Karte befinde.
Scamming, Future und... Nein. Nein.
Linux. Linux. Die Aussprache habe ich auch selten gehört.
Ich kenne Linux. Linux.
Aber Linux? Linux habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Das ist so...
Ubuntu.
Linux.
Ubuntu...
Ubuntu Linux.
2019, mit einem hohen NVIDIA GT 10.3 Video...
Was geht da los?
Das war nicht wahr.
Was passiert ist, dass, wenn du auf Google...
Open-Source-CMB-Drivers sind nicht nur sehr mature, sondern auch...
Jetzt, wenn du ein Budget-Game mehr bauen willst...
Was geht da los?
Mr. Amec, Twitch Prime, 3 Monate Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriber.
... ein System ist Linux, als ein Game in OS.
Im Falle, dass...
Wenn du einen OS für eine App suchst...
In AMD kannst du...
Auch für Linux...
Du siehst nicht so viel von der Leistungsdifferenz.
Also, für die meisten Sachen...
Du kannst...
Du hast ein Video, das auf Windows zu riesig ist.
io
Switching to Linux, ein Game Over-Screen.
Hör auf, Leute...
Sie sollen...
Es hat...
Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es hat auch wirklich keinen Sinn, und diese Videos haben wir nur...
Sie erreichen ja auch recht viele Leute.
Es hat doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass man...
Die Leute irgendwie einredet auf YouTube.
Dass, ähm...
Jetzt bei Windows 7 Support abläuft.
mal auf Linux zum Spiel ausprobieren. Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das führt einfach
nur dazu, dass die Leute frustriert sind und nie wieder was mit Linux zu tun haben wollen.
Ich bin auch kein Vertreter von Linux, ist gut für Gaming. Aber wie siehst du das mit
Konsolen? Bei der PS3 hat das ja funktioniert. Was? Was hat PS3? Du meinst Linux auf der
PS3? Ja, das hat aber nicht gut funktioniert. Linux auf der PS3, erstens haben sie das
dann rausgepatcht und 3 Wochen später war das Ding gehackt. Linux auf der PS3 hat nicht
gut funktioniert. Beispielsweise hatte die PS3 viel zu wenig RAM für Linux und die Linux
Distribution. Was war das? Jellodoc? Oder wie hieß das PS3 Linux? Jellodoc? Die hatten
auch das Problem, dass die keinen Zugriff auf die Grafikkarte hatten. Also das Linux
auf der PS3 hat nicht ordentlich funktioniert. Sponsor Block for YouTube. Oh, das hört sich
gut an. Was ist das denn? Sponsor Block for YouTube. Skipp Sponsorships. Woher weiß das
denn, wann man Sponsorships in Videos eingebaut hat? Ah, man muss es reporten. Okay, sprich,
das funktioniert natürlich nur bei Mindestmaß an Bekanntheit von diesem Video. Also sprich,
man sollte reporten, wann Werbung in dem Video ist und dann wird es geskippt. Ich finde das
cool, dass den Leuten immer wieder was einfällt, die Sache zu umgehen. Egal was man sich so
ausdenkt. YouTube und Twitch haben jetzt ja angefangen, dass Werbung und Ads werden von
den gleichen Servern rausgeschickt. Deswegen funktionieren so Sachen wie P-Hole und sowas
nicht mehr. Aber ich finde es geil, die Leute kommen immer wieder auf Ideen Werbung zu umgehen.
Glücklicherweise. So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal das mit dem Schloss an. Hat schon über
40.000 User. UBlock ist auch bald tot mit der neuen Chrome Version. Was, warum? Sollte
UBlock nicht mehr funktionieren, verwende ich kein Chrome mehr. Äh, UBlock funktioniert
deswegen, weil es nicht auf DNS-Basis funktioniert, sondern den Content der Seite ändern kann.
Was, Chrome, UBlock, warum sollte UBlock nicht mehr funktionieren? Die haben die Schnittstelle
abgeschafft für Adblocker. Hat echter Adshaft. Hä, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Also, sollten die, sollten die wirklich kein Adblocking mehr erlauben, werde ich kein
Chrome mehr verwenden? Also, ich werde instant kein Chrome mehr verwenden, wenn ich kein
Adblocker installieren kann. Das ist einfach, einfach vorbei. Warte mal, News. Hier, zeig
mal. Hä, ach so, Moment. Muss das ganze Ding kopieren, ne? Google implementiert umschrittenes
Manifest V3 in, von wann ist das? Naja, wenn sich da bis jetzt nichts getan hat. Mit dem
Regelwerk Manifest möchte Google umfangreich erinnern. Ähm, da Adblocker damit nun hat
Google. Das, also, sollte, sollte das kommen, werde ich instant aufhören, Chrome zu verwenden.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass das kommt. Die würden sich so krass damit ins
eigene Fleisch schleiden letztendlich. Die Seite sieht schon immer so aus. Ok, wir müssen
mal weiterhin, weiterhin suchen. Ähm, was, wie heißt das Ding? Manifest V3 habe ich ja
noch gar nichts von gehört. Adblock. Das ist alles so alt, ich glaube nicht, dass das
noch aktuell ist. Da stand im Februar 2020, wird das Update kommen. Compute by computer
failure. Adblock. Das ist alles? Das ist dann auch im neuen Edge, ja?
also bei Adblock geht es ja nicht darum, also bei U-Block geht es nicht darum,
dass es Ads blockt, sondern auch, dass es irgendwelche Seiten blockt, die komische Dinge
machen. Man ist, man ist einfach mit so einem Addon um ein vielfaches sicheres Internet
unterwegs. Ne, also ganz einfach, also sollte, sollte es dazu führen, dass Chrome nicht
mehr, also kein Adblock in Chrome funktioniert, werde ich kein Chroma verwenden. Das ist
ganz einfach. U-Block, U-Matrix habe ich eine Weile verwendet, das war mir zu anstrengend.
Ähm, ich habe ja davor jahrelang NoScript verwendet und da hatte ich die meisten Regeln
schon drinnen, die ich brauche und bei U-Matrix hatte ich keinen Bock, die nochmal neu anzulegen.
Mozilla hat gesagt, hier werden weitere Adblocks supporten. Ja, ganz ehrlich, es wäre, es
ist ja auch für Mozilla der logisch, der logischer Schritt, weil das wird ganz viele
Leute zu, zu Firefox bringen. Also das ist, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass die so blöde
sind in dem Fall. Es ist ganz einfach, sollte Chrome kein Adblock mehr unterstützen in der
jetzigen Form, dann wird Chrome einfach nicht verwendet. Das ist ganz einfach. Also das
ist die, eine der wenigen Sachen, die mich instant dazu bringen würde, ähm, einfach
kein Chroma zu verwenden. Woran erkennt man, ob die Adblocker dem Browser verlaufen? Gar
nicht. Zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres. Es sei denn, du kannst hier irgendwie den Source
Code angucken und äh, erfindest irgendwas, was trackt. Das ist dann aber für, für,
für unter Linux wieder so ein bisschen die Wahl zwischen Pest und Cholera, ne? Weil
aktuell ist es so, wer unter Linux, äh, Videos im Browser gucken will, dem bleibt bloß
ein gepatchter Chrome. Weil nur mit dem gepatchten Chrome kannst du unter Linux, äh, Hardware
Decoding im Browser verwenden von der Grafikkarte. Das heißt, du hast dann die Auswahl zwischen
Firefox, der kein Hardware Decoding unterstützt, dafür Adblocker, oder Chrome, der Hardware
Decoding unterstützt, aber keine Adblocker. Die Schaufel, also Linux auf dem Desktop schaufelt
sich langsam mit, mit ihren ideologischen Diskussionen selbst das Grab, äh, also warte
mal, das heißt, die gibt, es gibt ja gar kein Linux wirklich auf dem Desktop. Ähm, wie
gut läuft HLTP mittlerweile und nirgends kein Schimmer. Jetzt start doch mal das Video ab.
Warum kein P-Haul? Äh, weil das bei Seiten wie Twitch und YouTube mittlerweile nix mehr
bringt. Ähm, kennst du eine Werbung, Möglichkeit Twitch Werbung zu blockieren? Ja, Hublock,
äh, Browser Addons ist das einzige was geht. Du kannst auch einen Android Browser verwenden
mit, äh, oder Promite, es ist übrigens ganz gut Promite. Das ist übrigens ein sehr
nicer Android Browser. Das ist quasi ein Chromium mit Adblock und Gedöns reingepatcht.
Kammer, Kammer ist ziemlich gutes, ziemlich gutes Gesamtpaket. Ähm, und auf Twitch geht
das mit P-Haul nicht mehr, weil die DNS und Content, äh, weil die Werbung und Content
von gleichen Servern ausliefern, von gleichen Domains. Schläg? Das heißt, die heißt
doch bestimmt Schlage, oder? Das ist bestimmt was deutsches. Schläg, Schläg. Jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt kommen wir, das ist üblich bei ihm. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich drückt er
jetzt an zwei Stellen und das Schloss ist auf. Ah, yes, 2971. Ob alle Schlösser den
gleichen, den gleichen Code haben, den gleichen Standardcode? Moment, warum, ich seh's gerade
in der Browser Vorschau. Mein Video, mein, mein Stream hat die Text, Deutsch, Ask Me
Anything, Lehrreich, Programmierung, Softwareentwicklung, IRL und Ingenieurswesen. Warum hat mein Stream
die Text Ingenieurswesen? Das hab ich ja wohl irgendwann mal vergeben.
Ist das zu leise? Ah, das ist zu leise. Ich mach mal ein bisschen lauter. Besser, hm?
Ah, yes. Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommen die krassen Hacks, äh. Der sollte mal Lockpicking
erst am Arm machen. What? Oh. Nice.
Was er alles macht, ja. Ah, yes. Exzellent. Exzellent. So einfach ist es. Nice. Schlegg.
Ja, ich wollte schon immer die Türklinke nach innen machen. Wobei, die Amis schaffen
das. Die Amis schaffen auch, das nach vorne zu machen und das nach hinten. Und beschweren
sich dann dabei, dass es ihnen keiner gesagt hat, warum das Ganze gehörte. Das, das wäre
so richtig typisch Kona. Oh, jetzt kriegen wir hier die advanced Lockgeschichte gezeigt.
Okay, now we need to remove this back cap. Exzellent. Natürlich, was sonst? Legt ja auf
von innen aus. Habe ich noch nie gesehen. Exzellent. Now this core is interesting. Usually Schlegg
cores are made out of brass. This one seems to be cast from zinc. It's also pretty rare
for me to find drill protection in a Schlegg core. And that's exactly what we have right
on the front there. You can see a little plate of steel. So. It's a mixed bag. Let's take
a look at the driver pins now. Ich finde es ja geil, dass er so eine tolle Unterlage hat,
wo das alles reinpasst. Das ist richtig big brain Unterlage. This lock body also appears
to be cast zinc. Number one is a spool. Ah, natürlich. Spool, natürlich, das ist eine
Spool. Hätte dir was an, also ich hätte nichts anderes vermutet. Gleis. Spool, natürlich.
Logisch. And that's what we have. Auch eine Spool. Ah, yes. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was
gerade passiert. Ja, ich auch. So disappointed. Okay, ich habe das Schloss jetzt von innen
gesehen. Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer, was ich hier eigentlich genau sehe. Aber anscheinend
ist er damit ganz zufrieden, oder? Die Lockbox. Komm, eins gucken wir noch. Der macht irgendwie
sehr entspannende und interessante Videos zugleich. Wag. Wag. Wag. Wag. Wag. Wag. Wag. Wag. Wag.
Was? Habe ich das gerade richtig verstanden? Das Uber zum Gassi gehen. Sind das Leute,
die für dich Gassi gehen? Das sind Leute, die für dich Gassi gehen, oder? Wahrscheinlich
sind das Leute, die gehen für dich Gassi und du schließt deinen Hund da an, oder wie?
Alter, man muss seinen eigenen Hund immer... Egal. Egal. Egal. Just Kocona things.
Ah, yes. Das könnte ein Passwort von mir sein.
Oh. Easy. Easy. Easy. Easy as fuck.
Ach, da unten kommt der Haustürschlüssel rein oder was auch immer. Der Haustürschlüssel,
der Torschlüssel, der... Keine Ahnung, da wo der Hund drin ist, was auch immer. Irgendwas,
wo man dann aufs Grundstück an den Hund holen kann. Ach so. What?
Excellent. Einfach angucken, was man ganz aufmachen kann. Das ist natürlich auch highly
secure. Nee, das ist, glaube ich, eine ziemlich schlechte Idee, dort seinen Haustürschlüssel
reinzulegen. Na ja. Worst bei... Komm, eins guckt man auch. Ich finde das übrigens interessant
gerade.
Ohje. 1,9 Millionen. Haben wir ein Gartenstellensvideo, hat mehr Views.
Was haben sie da rein? Bestimmt Aliexpress.
Der Schneid ist da wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach durch.
Guckt euch das mal da unten an. Das geht schon kaputt, bevor du es verwendest.
Na gut, auf sowas kann man ja nur wirklich nichts geben.
Und die
Dann machen wir es wieder.
So, hier geht es.
Ok, wie ihr seht, ist die Pick-Rezistenz sehr, sehr klein.
Aber die hohe Pick-Rezistenz ist nicht genug, um den schlimmsten Lock in der Welt zu bezeichnen.
Ihr müsst viel mehr kaputt machen als das.
Also schauen wir uns an, was sie noch falsch gemacht haben.
Erstens, overall, Fit and Finish, die Konstruktion ist schrecklich.
Die ganze Sache fällt einfach weg.
Nichts, das zusammenhält.
Zuerst sieht Blush nicht so schlecht aus.
Wir haben hier diesen Locking Lug.
Und...
Mal sehen, es befindet sich an der Kurve.
Es sieht nicht so, als ob es Probleme gibt.
Es ist aus einem schönen, hartem Metall.
Was ist falsch mit dem Locking Lug?
Was ist falsch mit dem Locking Lug ist, dass es springlos ist.
Was können wir tun?
Springlose Locking Lugs?
Na ja, wir können sie schämen.
Also, sagen wir mal, dass dieses Ding das Bike auflockt.
Jemand kommt mit einem dünnen Stück Metall zusammen.
Sie können es einfach hier hinsetzen.
Schleißen es herum.
Haha, Wahnsinn!
Tolles, tolles...
Professionelle Wahl, Leute.
Professionelle Wahl.
Keine Fähigkeit bei dem Öffnen dieses Locking Lugs.
Also, was anderes haben sie falsch gemacht?
Na ja...
Ein Locking Lug sollte hart werden.
Es sollte hart werden, weil...
Es wird besser gegen Bultkotter und Verschleißer sein.
Und der beste Weg, um zu testen, ob ein Locking Lug hart ist...
Raufschlagen.
Ich habe schon ein paar Mal das Locking Lug getestet.
Ihr seht die kleinen Marken dort.
Und ich werde noch eins machen.
Dieses kleines Dschulersfile.
Ihr seht, dass es sehr, sehr leicht schrumpft.
Sicherlich nicht hart.
Irgendjemand hätte keine Probleme mit diesem sehr dünnen Locking Lug.
Und ihr seht, dass...
Ich habe es eigentlich getestet.
Es ist 0,8 Millimeter dick.
Ich denke, es ist ungefähr der gleiche Dichtung,
wie das Kürtelrad in meinem Schaum.
Sehr pathetisch.
Dann können wir auch den Schakel checken,
um zu sehen, ob das hart ist.
Und...
Ich habe schon ein kleines Knopf da drin.
Stimmt!
Es sind keine NA-Einheiten.
Okay, also es sackt.
Es ist nicht der Professional Choice.
Kein professionell choice deniedt.
Das kann sehr schnell ausgebildet werden.
Es fällt einfach weg.
Es riecht sehr schlecht.
Es macht meine Augen wunderschön.
Es wird aus sehr dünnen Materialen gemacht.
Was hältst du von ReactOS?
Es ist ein schönes Experiment.
Praktisch zu verwenden, eher weniger.
Das Meme-Hero-Video könnte man uns angucken.
Aber das ist mir zu lang.
Wir haben noch Battlefield-Top-Plays.
Ne, Lockpicking.
Nächstes Mal, nächstes Mal.
Und kannst du auch gerne ein Video von ReactOS machen?
Ja, das kann ich auch.
Das kann ich auch.
Nächstes Mal, nächstes Mal.
Und geh einfach zu ihm auf den Channel.
Geh einfach zu ihm auf den Channel.
Komm, wir gucken uns doch ein mw2-Video an.
Find my hiding spot in mw2.
Ach ne, das ist ein Challenges-Video mit Zuschauer.
Zum Abschluss...
Abschluss ok also ok wir gucken uns jetzt ein mw2 video an zum abschluss gucken wir uns ein mittagessen video an weil ich
Gehe dann gleich mittagessen
PC mw2
Random class generator nukes
Was krabi supreme kebab
Krabi supreme
Kebab
Das soll ich gucken
WTF
Was ist das
Ist das das hier
Ich weiß wie soll man das essen da kann man nur hoffentlich reinbeißen oder
Wahnsinnig gesund gibt es gibt es eigentlich gibt es die noch bacon strips bacon strips bacon strips die gibt es nicht mehr oder
Anscheinend gibt es anscheinend gibt es die wieder
Aber die sind bei weitem nicht mehr so viel so so gehyped wie früher
Kennt ihr das noch das war so zu zeiten wo wo wo fps rusher noch angesagt war bacon strips bacon strips bacon strips
Warcraft die forged
Reforged rejected refunded
Ja das ist auch schon wieder vorbei
geforged
BWM
Realistik military gases ja was gibt es da squad squad armor
Ja gibt es das auch so großartiges
Taghoff würde ich jetzt in warfare ist klar
Das halo speedrun in zwei minuten
Operation flay insurgency ja stimmt stimmt. Ja ja genau. Komm wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt am mw2 video
Oh my gosh, let's go. Let's double kill
Pepega set up. Oh my gosh, dude. I just got the new game last stand. Yeah, what is going on guys fortunate here
And today I'm bringing back a series. I used to be the best player in the game
I just got the new game last stand. Yeah, what is going on guys fortunate here and today bring you back a series I used to do
last
So I went on google and I looked up a random class generator for modern warfare 2 and I got three different classes that I'm going to be getting
nukes with the first one being the vector with thermal
Rangers akimbo frags done slight of and danger close. Yeah, what's up?
Yeah, got some decent killstreaks got harrier chopper gunner nuke and the second two will get to later on mw2. Eigentlich noch gespielt
Ja, ja auf der sowohl plekops 1 also mw2 werden auf der 360 beziehungsweise auf der xbox one mit backwards
Compatibility, dann noch gespielt ich habe letztens ein paar runden plekops also letztens über vier monate her oder so
Denke ob es eins gespielt und aufgenommen funktioniert gut video if you guys enjoyed this series and you want to see more of these let me know down in the comments also let's see if we could smash 2500 likes in the video and just so you guys know my code over at gfuel is 30% off verhackte log verhackte lobbies es geht das wichtigste ist dass man guckt dass man selbst host wird
Da gehen die meisten hacks nicht
11 so das vpn video
das war die stadt war trage gfuel für die 1st time 30% off ist ein big chunk of money und if you guys are brand new around here be sure to subscribe
macht er gerade sehr laut kann das sein
milestone i can't wait to hit anyways guys let's get right in the video
Mw2 hatte so viele sachen worüber man sich aufregen kann im nachhinein
muss muss man echt sagen das game war halt einfach zur richtigen zeit da
Ja
Aber mw2 hatte so vieles zeug was dich aufgedeckt hat das ist so der prototyp jedes modernen call of duties
Du konntest in mw2 auch random an so vielen sachen sterben
I did I'm sorry if my voice sounds a little crackly right now. I'm literally just woke up if you guys didn't know my
akimbo model
Was ist das für eine klasse
12 12 p.m. Wake up around to say up for most of the day then like eight o'clock it's in the air side
And I'm up all night again and basically repeat
I think they had a uav
BAM
Da war die leute haben immer so geflammt wenn du sie shotgun gekillt hast in mw2 ich habe heute noch auf meinem xbox account
flame messages die ich gekriegt habe von irgendwelchen kindern damals die sich aufgeregt haben weil ich sie in battle field 3 oder in
kot gekillt habe
Die spaß zwölf
Der keks hat eine muschi das ist ja schon wirklich uralt das kommt halt aber heute immer noch ab und zu mal
Hier können wir ein paar killen
Chopper
Spray Spray Spray
Ich weiß gar nicht warum sie mich angeschaut haben
Weil das pp gar gegner sind
Huge graphics guckt euch mal den boden an hier
huge graphics
Call this in real quick. Let's see if I can get some guilds dude if I can't get a little bit
No chance with my vector it's gonna be down to my chemo rangers
Let's see how this goes die nuke in mw2 war so einfach
Das das das war zu easy
Du musstest einfach nur eine gute lobby kommen
harry a chopper gunner oder AC 130 und
Das ist einfach nur passende lobby passendes killstreak sie ein paar kills machen easy
Easy nuke
Genauso einfach war das
Kennt ihr das auch noch in in in in kot ist immer so du hast den übelst geilen
Killstreak wirst gekillt und stirbst erst mal fünf mal bevor du ordentlich weiterspielen kannst
Heute geiern die alles runter das video ist relativ neu das video ist vom februar
Ja, aber es gibt bei weitem natürlich nicht mehr so viele kacknubs in dem game ja logisch
Das ist der aufsatz
Rechts der anfälle von
So much am I have already I got two kills oh wait I gotta call this in crap 70 200 calling the new did it. Do it. Do it
Spmm spiel das glaube ich deutlich zu wenig
Was für spiele spielst du aktuell aktuell spiele ich eigentlich nur das da
die aktuelle pass of exile league, wobei die aktuelle league ist ja mehr oder weniger
rum.
Ich bastel jetzt noch ein bisschen an meinem build rum, aber ich kann halt alles easy clearn.
Summoner builds sind halt opsfuck in dem game gerade.
Der unterschied zwischen meinem arc elementalist build und dem noob summoner builds sind halt
welten.
Bei dem einen musst du aktiv spielen und kriegst auf den sack wenn du scheiße baust und bei
dem anderen bist du halb afk und castest ein paar skelette und machst alles platt.
Jetzt sage ich mal hier AK47, red dot, throwing knife, slide open, zitrap, zitrap, zitrap,
was war denn das nochmal, ist das lauter hören, war zitrap lauter hören, kann mich da überhaupt
nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Da ist ein eagle smoke, airstrike, chopper gunner, tactic loot, das geht doch auch noch,
das ist doch auch noch vollkommen in ordnung.
Ach genau, das ist das was genau hier, man sieht ja schon was das equipment highlightet,
genau.
Oh, das wäre geil gewesen, da hätte ich den getroffen oder, das wäre cool, das wäre
cool gewesen mit dem besser, how are you standing by, wie man heute noch die sound samples kennt
von dem game, bombie, tango sucker, was überhaupt nicht tango sucker heißt, ja tommy das ist
alles op, in dem game war fast alles op, deswegen konnte dich in mv2 soviel random killen, ok
ok, also das war jetzt die ultimation, 2 kill auf dem chopper gunner, richtig pepega gegner
wieder am start, ooooh, ja warum nicht, weil er mit seiner geilen intervention rumschneibern
Frustrant.
Einer. Komm schon, Bro.
Lass dir deinen Kopf raus.
Ich versuche hier an der Seite zu rennen und sie zu finden.
Meine Teamkameraden töten alle.
Das wird das Beste.
Am besten ist MW2 immer noch der russische AC130 Ansager.
Der russische, der russische ist der beste.
Der russische ist der beste.
Das ist ja sofort am eskalieren der Ansage.
Das war der beste Ansage.
Er gibt sich wenigstens Mühe.
Der ist voll immersive.
Voll immersive Erfahrung.
Das ist die beste Map für Chopper Gunner und AC130 Wasteland.
Da kannst du sie so übertrieben zerstören.
Ich habe keine Ammo für das.
Oh, er wird abgeschossen.
Ich habe viel mit dieser Klasse gestorben.
Wie Highkey.
Ich liebe Wasteland.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, die Nuke sind zu einfach.
Ich meine, er macht 5 Kills und dann easy Nuke.
Das ist die Moab.
Stimmt.
Moment, das muss ich mir kurz geben.
Das ist die Moab.
Das war noch Zeit.
Was ist das für eine LMG?
M240.
Was ist das?
Ja, doch, genau.
M240 Heartbeat Sensor.
Da kann ich schon nicht mal vorwärts bewegen.
Und das ohne Nuke.
Okay, das ist ein absoluter Setup.
Let's go. Post-Migration? Okay, yeah, that one dude got kicked. Maybe they made me host, bro. I'd be so bummed.
Alright, let me one man army and get some ammo.
Tactical header.
Somewhere in that plane.
Shoutout to my teammate running the UAV.
Wow, the very last bullet.
It's five against three, right?
Na, doch, stimmt. Man hat ja mit one man army und change, hat man doch wieder Ammo gekriegt. Das hab ich ja ganz vergessen. Stimmt.
Deswegen haben die ganzen NoobTuber immer NoobTube one man army gespielt.
NoobTube one man army, irgendwo am Arsch der Welt rumgelegen und in eine Richtung in noobtubed.
How am I still alive?
Wisst ihr noch, wie das war, wenn jemand Painkiller hatte und du hast ihn gemessert? War der one hit oder two hit? Ich glaube, der war auch one hit.
One hit.
Messer war immer one hit, ne?
Der ist in den späteren Teilen, sodass nicht immer automatisch one hit ist.
Da steht er einfach. Da steht er einfach nach dem Spawn und bewegt sich nicht.
Die Map ist halt nicht so wahnsinnig gut für Chopper Gunner und AC One. AC One sollte noch besser, weil du das Kram wenigst explodiert, weil es wenigstens ordentlich explodiert.
Aber natürlich, wenn die Gegner sich nicht bewegen im Spawn, ist es natürlich noch besser.
Er braucht noch irgendwie zwei, drei Kills oder so.
Okay, Leute. Oh Gott, danke Gott, ich habe das pre-aimiert.
Oh Gott, los geht's.
Er braucht noch eins, zwei Kills. Er braucht nicht mal viel.
Oh Gott, Alter, ich habe gerade den Nuke in Last Stand bekommen.
Das ist wirklich der einzige Einsatz von Last Stand, den ich bisher innerhalb von zehn Jahren gesehen habe, der sich mal gelohnt hat.
Richtig MonkaS.
MonkaS, MonkaS, MonkaS.
Hoffentlich habt ihr das Video genossen.
Fakula Stand, der Steils-Clone.
Danke euch für das Zuschauen.
Wenn ihr es genossen habt, abonniert, wenn ihr neu seid.
Ich werde euch in der nächsten Folge treffen.
Klar erinnere ich mich an Fakula Stand.
Wer erinnert sich nicht an Fakula Stand?
Fakula Stand bedeutet keine Ein-Mann-Armee.
Kein Game-Ending-Nuke.
Kein Schuss-Grenzen-Zweifel.
Kein Commando-Perg.
Kein Last Stand.
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Typ geworden?
Was ist eigentlich aus dem geworden?
Video Game Investor
Nix irgendwie, ne?
Der macht nichts spannendes mehr, glaube ich.
Der hat ja da eine eigene Firma aufgemacht, die es nie geschafft haben, ein Game zu releasen.
Ah, yes, Investor Money.
Und...
Ich hab nix mal von ihm gehört.
Die ganze Zeit nicht.
Why did we stop play Battlefield 1?
Ganz einfach, wir haben erst gar nicht angefangen.
Und das wollte ich...
Also, das Game, ohne den Typ da drinne.
Das Game wollte ich schon lange mal weiterspielen.
Kein Essen oben rechts.
Ah, MW2 oben rechts.
Aber das dauert nicht lang.
Wenn wir ein bisschen refreshen, gibt es Essen oben rechts.
Fast, fast.
Krabby Patty.
Warum bauen die alle Spongebob-Butter nach?
Oh guck mal, ich krieg meine eigenen Videos empfohlen.
Ich krieg meine eigenen Videos empfohlen.
Poggers.
Pog.
Das Gothic Remake wird zacken, ey.
Wenn die wirklich das Remake so durchführen wie diese Demo, dann hat das, finde ich, mit dem alten Gothic nichts zu tun.
Leute, ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich streame mal ein bisschen kürzer, leider nur zwei Stunden.
Ich muss erstens mal übelst aufs Klo und hab übertrieben Hunger.
Kann jetzt leider nicht weitermachen.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht später.
Wir müssen ja noch die Geschichte mit der Heizung weiterprogrammieren.
Und vielleicht, vielleicht.
Mal gucken.
Also ihr wisst ja, wenn ich sage vielleicht heißt das wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Aber man muss mal schauen.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, den man hausten können?
Follow ich irgendjemanden, den man hausten können?
Zeig mal her.
Der Lost ist am Start.
Der hat aber immer genug.
Ähm.
Heizkohiros haben das letzte Mal schon gehostet.
Irgendwelche Grillstreamer, ja.
Nee, nee, nee. Ist grad nix dabei.
Gut.
Gut, alles klar Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis demnächst.
See you.